if the president had decided to stay
all gloves would have been off we would
have been back at war with the taliban
attacking our forces the offenses you've
seen throughout the country almost
certainly would have proceeded we would
have had about 2500 forces in country
with air power that would not have been
sufficient to deal with the situation
and i would be on your show right now
explaining why we were sending tens of
thousands of forces back into
afghanistan to restart a war that we
need to end
well that's secretary of state anthony
blinken this morning was defending the
president's decision to pull the plug on
afghanistan leading to the stunning
chaos that we are now witnessing dana
perino was here co-host of america's
newsroom and the five who served of
course as press secretary for president
george w bush who launched the war again
against terror and afghanistan in 2002.
dana um the administration seems to be
putting uh trying to at least put a a
positive spin on this evacuation
lincoln's saying it is orderly
that his is his word i mean how how do
you see it as we watch it in real time
well i respect the secretary of state
and i know that he certainly means well
and he's a patriotic american but i
think that the entire administration is
double parked in a no-good answer zone
and they put themselves in this position
they put the american people in a
position of watching a national
embarrassment and shame and humiliation
a defeat
that could have been more orderly i do
not understand and buy the argument that
they would have had to send in tens of
thousands more troops now they could
argue that president trump uh made a bad
deal with the taliban fine
but then you accepted it and you
implemented this and what i'm seeing
today sean is a complete and total
intelligence military policy and
diplomatic failure
and if the shoe were on the other foot
if there were democrats
if the republicans were in the majority
now and this was under a trump
administration you can bet what they
would be saying the best thing that they
could do right now is to own up to the
fact that the buck stops where it
actually stops which is at the
president's desk
and they have a emergency on their hands
in order to get the americans out and
get our allies out as soon as they
possibly can all those people that
helped us they are so far behind on
visas and the rest they made this
decision months ago and yet they've done
nothing to prepare for it
you make a point harry truman said the
buck stops here but look this is what
president biden said yesterday about
former president trump saying i
inherited a deal cut by my predecessor
which he invited the taliban to discuss
at camp david in the eve of 9 11 of 2019
that left the taliban in the strongest
position militarily since 2001 and posed
in may
1 2021 deadline on u.s forces
shortly before he left office he drew
the us forces down to a bare minimum
of a 2 500. we're showing the wrong uh
full screen there for a second but
basically what do you say when the when
when the
president trump's successor is pointing
the finger at him saying hey he made the
deal i'm sticking with his deal
he shouldn't have done it in the first
place
well again i think it looks uh churlish
and immature and i don't think that that
is leadership also i don't believe that
this kind of a drawdown had to be done
in this way i don't think that the
taliban would have said gosh we you need
eight more months we really can't accept
that we're just going to have to run
over kabul while all of your people are
there no that wasn't going to happen and
besides that if president biden really
believed it then why two weeks ago did
he tell everyone that this was never
going to happen that the very thing that
you are watching today
he said was never going to happen
so either they were delusional or they
were not listening to their intelligence
people
or they wanted us to believe something
else now they try to assuage their the
concerns by saying well polls showed
that americans wanted out of afghanistan
that's right they did but did they ask
the second question did they want to see
america in this position did they want
to see a chaotic
departure did they want to see all of
these people be slaughtered without any
sort of visa process or all of the
scrambling that has to be done and watch
what the subsequent polls say sean
those polls are not going to be kind
about this regardless of polls the right
thing to do is to try to get on top of
this immediately right now you know the
other thing sean that they said
they said that the taliban if they were
to do what they're doing right now today
was going to be isolated in the world
okay well what's happened in the last
few days
china russia pakistan and i'm sure to
follow the gulf states and iran
have all recognized the taliban as a
legitimate government so who's actually
isolated diplomatically now
uh yeah china's uh we're here is going
to recognize them and when china
recognizes the taliban they're in there
digging up all the minerals the gold and
everything else they can get their hands
on uh dana perino will be watching this
see you tomorrow
uh of course tomorrow okay thanks for
having me
of course thank you hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now